fatimata one pourquoi être les réactions
africaine à cette grande ukraine tenté
aussi d'en comprendre l'impact
économique absolument est pour l'heure
on ne peut pas dire que les réactions
soient très nombreuses on en a trois
types d condamnation immédiate sans
ambiguïté plutôt rare les mitigé les
absentes beaucoup plus nombreuses et
dans les réactions immédiates on
retrouve le kenya membre non permanent
du conseil de sécurité dont
l'ambassadeur martin qui manie avait
marqué les esprits dès lundi soir par sa
déclaration choc aux nations unies qui
avait fait un parallèle entre la
situation en ukraine et la colonisation
en afrique on écoute
le kenya comme la plupart des pays du
continent est née de la chute d'un
empire
nous n'avons pas décidé qu'elle serait
nos propres frontières elles ont été
dessinés par les lointaines puissance
coloniale de l'époque sans égard pour
nos anciennes nations mais à travers les
frontières nous parlons toujours des
langues communes nous avons des liens
culturels forts lors des indépendances
si nous avions choisi de bâtir des états
en fonction des ethnies des langues ou
des religions nous serions toujours
empêtrée dans un bain de sang nous avons
plutôt choisi de composer avec nos
nouvelles frontières et travailler à
notre grandeur et non pas de créer des
nations qui pense constamment au passé
avec une nostalgie dangereux nos stages
et puis les réactions un peu tardive
celle de l'union africaine par exemple
qu'à exprimer vers 18h à travers un
communiqué sa profonde préoccupation sur
les conséquences mondiales d'un conflit
et appelle au respect du droit
international service minimum et à
cesser le feu immédiat et prône un
dialogue diplomatique
mais évidemment l'absence de réaction de
certains et beaucoup plus remarqué
aucune réaction par exemple au mali pour
rappel elle est ciblée par plusieurs
sanctions à le mali depuis le deuxième
coup d'état je parle évidemment de la
junte de l'année dernière donc que la
jante est un peu occupé avec une
réaction avec une réunion cet après-midi
me dit on avec la cedeao on écoute de
son côté l'ancien premier ministre
malien moussa mara qui lui a réagi au
micro d'anne laure l'espion la
destruction n'a jamais été une chose
cause la guerre n'a jamais été une chose
positive moi je suis du mali le mali a
été occupée et le mali et victime aussi
de temps en temps 2 tentation de
séparatisme donc je ne peux pas ne pas
être sensible aux questions ukrainienne
il faut que le droit international soit
respecté que la souveraineté des pays
soient respectés que la souveraineté de
l'ukraine qui est un pays de connu
internationalement y compris par la
russie soit respecté et je pense que il
est aussi toujours tant que la
diplomatie puisse prévaloir donc demandé
à la fédération de russie tient grand
pays de bien vouloir reconsidérer sa
position et de continuer à privilégier
la diplomatie
l'impact économique et alors il faut le
dire clairement la russie n'est pas un
très grand partenaire économique du
continent africain appelle 20 milliards
de dollars par an soit 10 de comparaison
cela chine c'est dix fois plus et le
secteur de prédilection de la russie
c'est l'armement mais depuis quelques
années on remarque une certaine d'isère
diversification des intérêts russes sur
le continent notamment depuis 2014 et
les sanctions occidentales suite à
l'invasion de la crimée aujourd'hui il
exporte des céréales et les
hydrocarbures et sa première zone d'
influence sur le continent africain
c'est le maghreb et on retrouve notre
correspondant edouard dropsy au caire
qui revient sur la déclaration quoique
un peu lapidaire est mitigé du pouvoir
égyptien face à la guerre que mène la
russie en ukraine et nous explique
notamment les potentielles conséquences
sur l'économie de l'egypte on écoute le
gouvernement égyptien a réagi quelques
heures après l'invasion du territoire
ukrainien par la russie dans un
communiqué liminaire de quelques lignes
le ministère des affaires étrangères a
appelé les parties au dialogue pour je
cite ne pas troubler encore plus les
équilibres régionaux et mondiaux sans
toutefois condamné l'invasion du
territoire ukrainien par la russie alors
pourquoi une telle prudence de la part
du gouvernement égyptien et bien d'une
part les égyptiens sont dépendants de
l'aide financière américaine chaque
année 1 3 de dollars et versé au
gouvernement égyptien dont de l'aide
militaire et c'est donc un partenaire à
ne pas froisser et de l'autre côté en
tant qu'acteur d'un monde multipolaire
le président 6 6 a multiplié ces
dernières années les accords bilatéraux
avec des puissances telles que la chine
ou la russie une autre question se pose
l'egypte est le premier importateur
mondial de blé chaque année 13 millions
de tonnes la russie lui en fournisse 50%
l'ukraine 30% donc la question se pose
de savoir si les prix vont augmenter
pour plusieurs économistes ce ne sera
pas le cas notamment parce que désormais
le gouvernement égyptien à 6 mois de blé
dans ses stocks encore faut-il que le
conflit ne perdure pas c'est tout pour
les réactions africaine pour l'instant
merci fatimata